does your organization use software as a
service workloads is the data in those
workloads properly protected
let's look at this
today most organizations have an I.T
infrastructure that relies on software
as a service or SAS workloads workloads
like Microsoft 365. Salesforce Microsoft
Azure Google workspace and many many
more
there are good reasons why the software
as a service model has taken off
primarily it's because by putting all of
the data into one location in the cloud
where it's always up to date and can be
accessed globally even Via Mobile for
your authorized users that adds
tremendous value and simplifies business
operations
but it's important to understand that
when we're backing up this data it's
more than just numbers and Text data
seems a little bit vague but let's look
at what we're really concerned with here
let's say you have some data
well another way of looking at this is
you actually have i t infrastructure in
your data center you've got a whole
bunch of server racks with all kinds of
storage and processors going on
but what is really a threat is not just
the data it's the entire it
infrastructure and when you look at it
the data that's in that it's the
calendars emails the shared folders your
customers your invoices your
transactions they're really crucial
parts of your organization's operations
and so in a worst case scenario we can
imagine that what's really at threat
healer isn't just your data this is
actually your entire organization facing
an existential threat because of the
loss of this data and this is what keeps
your CIO or your CEO or your ciso the
Chief Information Security Officer up at
night the constant risks what are these
risks well to start with they are so
prevalent that now in the most recent
survey that IBM did in August of 2022
where they surveyed more than 3 000
organizations to identify the cost of a
data breach there were a couple of
shocking numbers the first one was that
86 of companies reported that they've
been struck by malware more than once in
the previous year more than once and in
the United States the average cost of
one of those malware attacks was 9.4
million dollars so there are really
significant costs associated here and
what we need to do is look at how we can
solve that problem by beefing up the
data protection part of your software as
a service infrastructure
so let's look at what capabilities you
would need in a software as a service
data protection solution
well the first is that if you're going
to be protecting data from a specific
workload it's really important that you
have tight integration with that
workload
so when you want to look at backing up
some data you want the ability not to
just back up an entire data set but to
delve deeply into how the data is
structured and be able to capture the
relationships the custom fields and all
of the other crucial data in that
application
secondly when you're doing backups you
really want greater control over when
they occur many SAS platforms are
limited in how often you can back up or
how frequently or or or when you can
back up you need to be able to set that
automatically and according to your
business requirements
the next big issue is what is it that
you're backing up
because rather than backing up the
entire data set which could take a long
time and may not be necessary with good
SAS backup Solutions you're able to
specify down to the metadata level
exactly what data it is that you want
recovered
now the next key point is where are you
going to store that data
well the choice is between the platform
that's provided by your SAS provider or
whether you have choices to store it in
your own cloud private Cloud public
cloud and that's a great flexibility
that's really important to a lot of
companies and then the finer one is that
good SAS backup Solutions
have enhanced compliance and security
features which are really important
today
so let's look at what the backup
capability would need to include well
we've seen that we need more frequent
backups we need greater control over
what those backups contain we need to
control where they're stored and we need
to have increased security and
compliance with all of these
capabilities I think we can really begin
to address the bottom line and what is
the bottom line here it really is the
bottom line the profit and loss
statement for your company because this
is not just about losing your data it's
about losing your organization's ability
to operate
so if your company relies heavily on
data in your SAS workloads then SAS
backup software might be a good fit for
your organization
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe
if you have questions please drop them
in the comments below